the first ambulance strike in 30 years
obviously cases will have to be
prioritized if an old person has a fall
is that a priority well what the trade
unions have said and we all recognize
that our paramedics and those across the
NHS have been under huge pressure from
the pandemic and that's why in the
Autumn statement we prioritize funding
for the NHS and we're working very
intensively to get more numbers of
paramedics training more paramedics 3000
a year we're recruiting more 40 more
since 2010 but in terms of what will be
covered by the strikes we're discussing
that with the trade unions they have
said that they will cover
life-threatening conditions
tends to be less those sort of cases
they're usually called a cat three so
there's four categories of call
life-threatening which is category one
emergency which is category two those
tend to be things like heart attacks and
strokes so your case k would often be
classed as a category or category 4 at
the moment the trade unions are saying
those things wouldn't be covered right
okay what if somebody has a heart attack
you're saying that wouldn't be covered
either well the indication from the
trade unions is that it would uh but
obviously there's distance somebody has
a stroke well we're having in those
discussions obviously the Trade union
said to us they didn't want to get into
the details of exactly what uh what
derogations what things would be covered
and what would not until they'd
announced the date of the strike and now
they have done that uh there's
discussions that will take place
tomorrow in terms of what exactly will
be would you expect a stroke to be
covered if somebody had had a stroke
would you expect the ambulance service
well firstly I hope that we don't have
the strikes and part of the reason as a
government we have prioritized the
funding for the NHS we have accepted in
4k the recommendations on the
independent pay review body we also last
year already expected inflation to be as
high as it is well if you were to give
everyone in the public sector a pay rise
in line with inflation that will cost at
28 billion pounds and I think many of
your viewers who are facing pressures
with the cost of living would would say
a further 1000 cost for them on each
household to pay 28 billion extra at a
time of cost of living pressure would be
too much so we have an independent
payview new body for a reason to look in
the rounds they came up between before
they came up with this yeah and we have
accepted that K in full so it was set to
the independence independent process
that looks at what the right level of
pain let me just pick up on something
you said there you said that you know
you're hoping to not have the strike on
the 21st of December does that mean that
you are planning more talks
I'm open to talks with the trade unions
I've not said any preconditions on that
I'm willing to meet them and meet them
today my door is open I've been very
clear that I will engage with them
um but if they do want to go ahead with
the Straits then obviously it's
important we look at what is covered
within the delegations what areas and I
agree with you that it is important
particularly where we have life
threatening treatments that those things
are covered by the strike you say your
door is always open Rachel Harris in the
GMB National secretary says Steve
Barkley needs to listen and engage with
us about pay if he can't talk to us
about this most basic Workforce issue
what on Earth is he Health secretary for
well the trade unions themselves have
said to me it's not just about pay
they've said there's many issues that
affect staff the quality of the NHS
estate the tech and whether that is
helping them uh safety of Staff Staffing
levels so there's a range of issues that
the NHS unions have said that matter in
terms of pay we have an independent
process which looks at these issues in
terms of what's the right balance for
your viewers in terms of their taxes The
Wider pressures that the economy is
under and let me put this we've only got
to find out about your time as you know
Minister the Royal College of Nursing
um their General Secretary Pat Cullen
saying you're refusing her request for
negotiations no what I'm saying is I'm
very happy to have talks with them
there's a range of issues
when I met with patch you raised a
number of issues of concern pay was one
but it wasn't the only one and I'm very
keen we work with the trade unions
constructively we look at the issues in
terms of Staffing levels
it's wrong to say that you that you are
refusing is because they are the ones
that have said that they they want to
negotiate on this year's pay alone as a
precondition when there are a range of
issues that the trade unions say matter
to their staff okay and it's important
we work together on those things talk to
me about the backlog caused by covid
what we're going to do about that well
there is and and you're absolutely right
to say that it's driven by covid if you
look at where we were before the
pandemic and the number of people
waiting say 52 weeks for an operation
1300 to where we are now which is over
400 000. it's very clear these are
challenges that are predominantly driven
by the pandemic that's why we've got a
task force being launched in number 10.
today we're opening another 19 Community
diagnostic Centers that's building on
the 91. we've already done those 19 will
be an extra 1 million of tests because I
think what many viewers want to know is
given the backlogs we Face from the
pandemic are we doing everything
possible in government to be Innovative
to set up new diagnostic Centers to set
up new surgical herbs and that's what
we're prioritizing and I think when we
do look at the discussion on pay if we
were to meet the unions to land which is
a 19 increase which is about three times
more than many of your viewers
themselves will be receiving that 19
million would make it 19 would make it
much more difficult for us to get the
backlogs down and to invest in things
like the community diagnostic Centers
got it why hasn't Michelle Moon had the
whip removed well she's taken the leave
of absence
well matters incense of the weapon
always for the the chief Whip and that's
a long-standing convention but she's
taken the leave of absence from the
House of Lords so she's not able to go
to the House of Lords and it's right
that these issues are investigated and
that's what the department is doing and
that's what the house of laws
authorities are doing did you have any
dealings with her at all during that
time no nothing at all no well
but you were in the treasury I was in
the treasury yeah she didn't approach it
the best of my knowledge no I can't uh
I'm certain not
um she apparently sent threatening
emails to ministers and to the Chief
Operating Officer of NHS Western Trace
is this the first time you're hearing
about this when you read about it in the
guardian I wasn't aware of that so so
yes
um but I think it's important that these
are looked at uh properly professionally
and that where the House of Lords are we
investigating this which I understand
they are that there's a due process
around that and you don't feel that it
would be appropriate for her to have the
whip room are you happy that somebody
who is apparently behaving in this
manner can still say that she's a
conservative and represent your party in
the House of Lords well my understanding
she's taking the Libre up volition
investigated as I say issues there's a
very long-standing convention that when
it comes to issues of who has the Whip
or not we have a chief width that makes
those is it because the prime minister's
not really in charge at the moment I
mean there's another U-turn last night
when it came to the onshore wind farm so
I think you can see actually the fact
that the Prime Minister has taken a very
strong stand in terms of the priority of
getting inflation down because we all
recognize that unless U-turn again well
I think it's important that we listen to
colleagues that is our parliamentary
process and it's important that we do
these things with local consent and so
what we're saying in terms of onshore
wind is we recognize as well absolutely
not in the summer we recognize there
must be pressure in terms of energy
bills that's why we've got the package
in terms of the 900 pounds of support
this year 500 pounds of support yes so
you're part of that wider cost still a
YouTube package so and that's also when
we look at the challenge we have in
terms of the trade unions and pay it's
important we look at that wider cost of
support well as I say I think listening
to colleagues is a good thing and
ensuring that where communities have
onshore wind is done with their consent
and we're listening to those communities
okay and I need to let you go but just
to clarify you will let people know by
the by the end of today tomorrow what if
they need an ambulance how you're going
to categorize it well it will be the
trade unions that will say what they
will cover within the strike action we
will then obviously put contingency
places continue using measures in place
as best we can to mitigate where there
are shortages good to see thanks for
joining us on the program thank you very
much indeed